(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Chinese COVID-19
vaccines are being used
in dozens of countries.
- China has donated vaccines everywhere
for those countries who need help.
- [Narrator] But these shots have some
of the lowest efficacy rates
among globally used coronavirus vaccines,
ranging between 50 to nearly 80%.
Compare this with shots from
Pfizer-BioNTech, Moderna
and Russia's Sputnik V.
The head of China CDC in
early April said the efficacy
of some vaccines was not high.
And this also included
ones from his own country.
So China is looking to
bolster the protection rate
and one way is to mix and match
different types of vaccines.
And this idea isn't new.
- We really welcome studies
that would look at mix and match regimens.
- [Narrator] Spain is also
interested in combining vaccines
while researchers in the UK
and Russia are already studying this.
So as China joins the ranks
of countries looking to mix and match,
here's how it can be a key
to overcoming multiple
vaccination challenges at once.
Most Chinese vaccines and
other shots currently in use
require two doses, creating an
opportunity to mix and match.
Some immunologists believe
this could have a number
of benefits like boosting
the immune response.
- The theory is that if
you train the immune system
to recognize a virus in a
slightly different way each time,
then you might get a broader
and more durable immune response.
- [Narrator] And a more
robust immune response
is important since China
has confirmed cases
of new and more transmissible variants
that were first identified
in the UK and South Africa.
Mixing and matching for this
reason has gotten support
from at least one Chinese
drug maker so far.
Some immunologists also say
that mixing and matching
could ease the pressure
from the vaccine supply chain.
So for example,
in countries that are
rolling out Chinese vaccines
along with other supplies,
using two different shots
could give doctors more options
when patients come in for the second dose.
But one of the most important reasons
is when there are severe side effects
from one of the vaccines.
- If someone perhaps has a strange
or severe allergic reaction to
the first shot that they get,
perhaps then you could avoid that
by giving them the second
dose from a different vaccine.
- [Narrator] The idea became
particularly important
after regulators started investigating
rare blood clotting disorders linked
to AstraZeneca's COVID vaccine.
As of late March, 79 people in the UK
have had severe blood clots
out of the 20 million administered doses
of AstraZeneca's vaccine.
In France and Germany,
health authorities are
advising younger people
who have received a
first dose of AstraZeneca
to get a second dose
of a different vaccine.
The drug maker said it's
working with health regulators
and starting the rare
blood clotting events
and possible causes.
While these upsides could
bring China and other countries
closer to getting their
population vaccinated,
health authority say
there's still a lot to learn
about possible side effects
or how it may affect efficacy
of the vaccines, especially when it comes
to combining shots made
with different technologies.
- The vaccine, such as Chinese vaccine
and the vaccines by AstraZeneca
and Johnson & Johnson
are vaccines that use
a virus as the vector
to get the genetic
instructions into your body.
- [Narrator] Whereas
Pfizer-BioNTech and Moderna vaccines
use a new gene-base technology
involving messenger RNA,
where molecules carry
genetic instructions.
- So we're not too sure what happens
when you mix these two
technologies together.
- [Narrator] Chinese health
authorities have said people
can receive different brands
that use the same technology,
but don't recommend mixing vaccines
with different technology so far.
But now trials with the combination
of two homegrown vaccines
with different technologies
are underway in China with
more than a hundred volunteers.
The country is also working
on its own mRNA vaccine
and looking closely at
approving Pfizer-BioNTech shot,
according to people
familiar with the matter.
This would pave the way
for China to mix and match
its more conventional
vaccines with mRNA shots.
Similar to how researchers
in the UK are studying
the combination of AstraZeneca
with Pfizer-BioNTech or Moderna.
Those results are expected as early as may
- Immunologists, when you speak to them
about this sort of process, are
pretty enthusiastic about it
and optimistic that it's going to work.
But that's maybe the one big drawback
is we want to make sure that it works,
we want to make sure that it isn't worse,
you don't get a worse immune response
than if you had two doses
of the same vaccine.
(gentle music)